la cuisine autochtone est peu présente
en restauration mais la faire connaître
et aimer c'est la mission que c'est
lancé le chef Jerry Brandon notre
journaliste Gilda menu la rencontrer au
témiska magontarien
[Musique]
NES du lac demis kaminck Jerry Brandon
et sa femme Nancy ont ouvert un
restaurant gastronomique unique en son
genre l'autochtone taverne américaine
est d'origine anischinabé mais a été
adopté dès sa naissance par un couple
blanc
Jerry c'est beaucoup promené en Amérique
du Nord comme chef dans de grands
restaurants il est de retour au bercail
pour faire rayonner les cultures
culinaires autochtones
Jerry souhaite avant tout travailler
avec les producteurs locaux
[Musique]
de la ferme bison du Nord située tout
près à Horton est une cliente régulière
du restaurant de Jerry Brandon
aujourd'hui elle lui apporte un morceau
de filet
après l'avoir enrobé d'une marinade
sèche d'inspiration Aztèques Jerry l'a
fait cuire sous vide puis la saisie
rapidement c'est certain que ça a un
élément plus spécial pour moi parce que
c'est notre bison on faillite
la ferme bison du Nord puis être capable
de faire une collaboration avec un chef
local c'est vraiment tout ce qu'on
espère dans notre industrie et puis
vraiment nous le présenter comme ça
c'est magnifique
le bison symbole par excellence des
cultures autochtones
alors la viande est d'une tendretée
incroyable vraiment le ça doit être le
sous vide aussi qui est
délicieux
c'est vraiment délicieux c'est magique
Jerry nous propose aussi sa version des
3 soeurs bien connue dans la cuisine
autochtone maïs courge et haricots le
sicotage est un ragoût de ces légumes à
la sauge qui accompagne un ravioli farci
aux légumes et aux jaunes d'œufs coulant
vraiment très très bon ce sont trois
légumes qui se marient très bien en fait
c'est vraiment délicieux je vais faire
ça maintenant à la maison
mon expérience quand je suis venue au
restaurant pour la première fois c'était
de voir qu'il y avait des éléments des
trois témiscamings en fait
première nation Jerry a bien l'intention
de continuer à innover et à expérimenter
dans sa cuisine
on apprécie beaucoup la bonne bouffe on
aime sortir avec nos amis on aime avoir
les expériences gastronomiques donc
vraiment on peut pas demander mieux pour
notre petite région alors santé
jacinthey
[Musique]